hey we're here at movieclips and we're
talking about our top five most
anticipated movies of 2014 in no
particular order first up we have x-men
Days of Future Passed directed by Bryan
Singer I'm really excited for this movie
yeah it's it's if the movie even if the
movie stinks it's a feat just of
agent scheduling actors together we have
every x-man who's ever been in an x-men
movie so this is possibly the largest
conglomeration of superhero stars ever
put together and also you said Bryan
Singer from the first two x-men movie
widely considered the best of the x-men
movies is back directing which is really
really exciting but it's based off the
comic that from the 80s in which Kitty
Pryde is sent back in time to stop an
assassination but this time it's
Wolverine because he's more popular also
it's this is one x-men Days of Future
past is written by Chris Claremont in
the 80s like you said and it's kind of
known as one of the kind of seminal
x-men stories when people think of like
what are the best x-men stories ever
told in the comics Days of Future past
is always one of the first things to
come up so it's really exciting to see
that finally comes of the screen next on
our list is the amazing spider-man 2
this is Marc Webb
you know carefully named and he's
returning to direct the second what do
you guys think of the first book were
you guys I liked the first one I was a
huge fan so it's a little unnecessary to
show Uncle Ben dying again yeah but I
really like Andrew Garfield as an actor
I really like the world they're sort of
modernization that Marc Webb is doing
and I love the trailer for the amazing
spider-man 2 that recently came out
about a month ago I'm also I'm over the
moon about the trailer I thought the
first one in a world where we're
supposed to pretend that the first three
spider-man movies don't exist and with
the third one I've already been doing
that for years so I think that it was a
really really good spider-man movie
there were problems with villains and
stuff like that but it was it was
absolutely had great moments enough for
me to be super excited about this film
and Jamie Foxx as electro is probably
one of the most exciting aspects
about this Anja we looked at the trailer
and we counted a lot of villains yeah we
got the Rhino Electra we have
implications of Doctor Octopus and The
Fault rate of and and Green Goblin like
straight-up see me at least he had the
Green Goblin that was like sort of a
secret for a while and now we see
pictures so sort of Geary towards the
sinister six so this is gonna become you
know such a bigger part of you know what
Sony owns of the Marvel Pie so next up
moving on with Marvel phase two this
year we have guardians of the galaxy
directed by James Gunn which is the
coolest thing about this is that it's
directed by James Gunn he's been kind of
this weird indie filmmaker he made
movies like slither and super like
really strange kind of oddly tone movies
and from the post product credit
sequence that we saw after Thor the dark
world I believe yeah this movie feels
already different from every other
Marvel movie in the universe it has a
different look at different feel and we
have a raccoon named Rocket Raccoon
voiced by Brad Cooper we're supposed to
be like the breakout character for this
movie and I've also written a lot of
interviews it's gonna be like on par
with it you know Star Wars style likes
the lasers and photons and everything's
just going to be super sci-fi like a
space opera kind of getting that's
really cool I've only just started
reading the guardians of the galaxy
comics but I mean there's a lot of new
characters to get introduced to because
I don't think a lot of people know about
these James Gunn is a little worrisome
to me just because some of the films you
have mentioned I haven't liked a lot of
his movies but the prospect of him
directing this makes me really excited
all right next up we have godzilla this
is a bryan cranston is in this movie and
uh Aaron taylor-johnson I believe
kick-ass and Jen wants a nabi the cast I
love and I thought the trailer was
amazing yeah it was the visuals that he
puts forth in the trailer from like the
jumpers coming out into the clouds and
just like how we see Godzilla and all of
the aesthetics of you know like bunkers
I mean it's like it's a movie about a
giant monster there's gonna be a
military presence everything about this
movie excites me especially him his
presence and Elizabeth also especially
after Pacific Rim in saying the way
monsters fight in cities in the way that
I guess since the 1950s you know we
don't have puppets anymore even though I
do love that aesthetic I think the way
visual effects of
it's formed over the years like this
could be the best Godzilla movie ever if
anyone seen Matthew Broderick's Godzilla
the visual effects were pretty low
because we finally were at the point
where technology can handle that kind of
story and they've already hinted that
there may be the presence of more than
one kaiju in this that yet there could
be a Mothra that could be yeah and if
that I mean if that's the case it'd put
it to more than my number one most
anticipated may 2014 its of all time
finally we have Christopher Nolan's
interstellar now he's had free reign for
a while now to do whatever he wants a
big-budget blockbuster last time he
cooked up inception which I thought was
phenomenal I thought was the best
blockbuster in year that's when he was
doing his like favorite movie yeah they
will let you make this one yeah I'm a
huge I guess fanboy for Christopher
Nolan prestige memento Inception The
Dark Knight movies and lastly the bad I
mean this is stuff that he and his
brother right I think are amazing and
I'm pretty sure his brother John helped
him with this one as far as right well
Jonah Nolan or Jonathan Nolan originally
wrote this for Steven Spielberg who's
been developing this story which is
based on the theories of black holes
which like really means it's based on
nothing he wrote it for Steven Spielberg
who's been developing it for like a
decade and then Christopher Nolan took
it and was like I got a you know rewrite
this in my own style so you know there's
gonna be a dead woman in it and no humor
and it's gonna be really really long
yeah so I mean it's a big year for
movies we're excited about these but
you're probably excited about different
one so comment below let us know what
you think of these movies and all the
others that are coming out in 2014 and
check out our other video where we talk
about 2014 a year and preview where we
you know we're gonna preview and talk
about the other movies like Maleficent
Robocop edge of tomorrow 22 Jump Street
maybe other big movies that are ready
like really gonna be cool till next time
I'm David jeaious and I'm Ryan thank you
for watching